I became a set decorator basically after
I went to college which I had studied
art at UCLA and at calarts and I was a
photographer so I was used to telling
visual stories i loved i was obsessed
with photography and i was working in
fashion and a friend of mine said do you
want to work on a film and I was like
yes absolutely and it was for Michael
Jermain on heaven's gate so I worked on
that film and then I worked for Hal
Ashby for four years basically and learn
it was my film school I learned all
about every department it was the 80s it
was a pretty naughty time was pretty
crazy I learned things I didn't want to
know but I learned every every
department and I was attracted of course
to the art department and one day house
said to me what do you want to do in
film and I said I wanted to be a set
decorator and he said you're fired go do
it and it pushed me to make a move and I
was very fortunate to get a film and I
committed to that art making process
with collaboration with other people and
I loved it I loved their bit of it and I
continued on fortunately to tell the
visual story requires so many different
aspects it's not just finding objects
it's doing your research and
understanding the characters we're here
to serve the story and to talk about and
show in a visual way who the characters
are so I think the misconception is that
it's a much it's it's a very large job I
mean you have so many different aspects
that you have to be involved in I would
imagine the psychology of each of each
character that's written how they live
where they live what they do you have to
do tremendous research to create that
character and it's not always in the
script of course so you get to use your
imagination which is the fun part and
you collaborate with your director and
your cinematographer and your production
designer and hopefully you go on the
right path well most immediate change is
through the internet and the speed in
which we were expected to do things I
think it's been a great tool for
research but it also has forced us to
change our methods of research and how
we do things you know it we used to go
out all the time for similar just
shopping and go to swap mates or it's a
stores or to prop houses you know we
could go online and buy things on ebay
and have it sent to you so it's a time
saver but it's also you lose that
connection I mean I feel like I really
miss hand drawings from set designers
because everything's done on the
computer it lacks a little bit of soul
sometimes for me a bit old-fashioned
that way but I still like going out in
the world and looking for things I mean
that's the passion and an obsession you
have in a one finds just the right
perfect object and you know you want to
put your hands on it